Good morning, Hank, It's Tuesday.
I woke up at 4:10 AM on Sunday and got into
a car with Sarah.
How you feelin' Sarah?
Sarah: Poorly.
John: And drove through the dark to the Indianapolis
Airport, got through security and picked up
The New York Times because my editor and publisher,
Julie Strauss Gabel, was profiled in it.
Then I took a brief nap which Sarah was kind
enough to video, got on the plane, read a
great profile of Toni Morrison, and enjoyed
the view, and five short hours later, we landed
in Los Angeles, where, of course, sunshine
and blue skies, because: drought.
Got a car to the hotel, took a nap which ended
when you called me, opened the window to briefly
contemplate the role of the palm tree in the
California landscape, but then I got distracted
by the huge pile of books in my room.
I wasn't sure what they were for but I signed
them out of habit.
Lunch came via room service, but we were tight
on time, so I had to get in the bath.
I know I could have saved time by showering,
but showers are disgusting; having water droplets
pelted at you like an attack from above is
just uncivilized.
Plus there's the indignity of not being able
to eat while getting clean.
I ironed my shirt, got my make-up done -- God,
I love make-up! -- and prepared for the MTV
Movie Awards.
I'm sorry Hank, I was about to tell you that
I'm dressed, but, in fact I'm not because
there's been a sock emergency: we're changing
socks.
Now I am dressed.
Also, I've switched to the iPhone camera for
subtlety, so sorry about the shaking.
We met up with Elise and drove past yet more
palm trees to a different hotel where there
was Justice Smith a.k.a.
Radar,
How are you?
Justice Smith: I'm so good!
Also Alex Wolff and Nat Wolff, seen here getting
his hair done.
And then we drove to the awards.
Fans:
*Screaming*
John: Maybe at some point that will stop being
weird, but not yet.
Hank, it's difficult to express the intense
and overwhelming strangeness of this stuff.
I mean I was happy to be there, and happier
and more grateful still to be there with friends
and family, but in this moment, one feels
that these photographers are imagining you
as an object that they need to acquire rather
than, like, an actual human being.
How does this feel, Alex?
Alex Wolff: Terrifying.
John: And, in turn, it's very difficult to
feel like they are actual people, like the
kind who, as Whitman beautifully put it, "contain
multitudes".
Instead, it feels like they are objects, clicking
cameras, and your overriding concern is that,
in the brief photographic intersection of
light and time, the object version of you
that they capture is not, like, picking its
nose or doing that weird thing with its smile
it sometimes does.
But then it was over, and Cara Delevingne
showed up and she always makes me feel better
at this stuff because she knows just how to
handle it all, and she and Nat and I got to
introduce a clip from Paper Towns of Q and
Margo Nair-ing off Chuck's eyebrow.
And then we were rushed in to the show itself
which was really fun, except the whole time
I was distracted by this giant, thin-legged,
popcorn bucket that seemed to be staring at
me in a vaguely lascivious way.
I'd be like, "Oh this is fun, I'm havin' fun,
oh yeah, I could dance a little bit," and
then God that giant popcorn is still looking
at me!
But anyway, Shailene won for best actress
for her role in The Fault in Our Stars, and
she was so kind about me in her acceptance
speech that she made me cry.
And then during the commercial break I was
still crying and Nat told me, "This would
be really touching if you didn't cry over,
like, a good meal," which, you know, fair
enough.
And then, The Fault in Our Stars won for best
movie, and everyone had told me that, if we
won, I should make the acceptance speech so
that I could thank Esther, and I got to, and
it was amazing, and I know it's not the Oscars
or anything, but whatever; it was our Oscars,
and it was so great to be there with Nat and
Justice and Cara and Shai, and to have this
moment to feel grateful for The Fault in Our
Stars at the same time as I could feel excited
about Paper Towns.
Right, so go back to those famous L.A. palm
trees, for a second; they are not native to
Los Angeles, and, in fact, can't survive there
without copious amounts of watering.
They're cool and beautiful and totally unsustainable
and unnatural, much like the whole screaming
machine of celebrity.
But later at a restaurant with my friends,
like, the real complicated, multitudinous
people who made The Fault in Our Stars and
Paper Towns, I kept thinking about how we
actually care about each other and hold each
other up.
Not just when the cameras are off, but especially
when the cameras are off.
And then my friend and movie producer, Isaac,
made me turn my camera off which was the best
part of a very good and very long day.
Hank, I'll see you on Friday.